[Music]
in the dense forests of central and
south america lives the most formidable
predator of the sky
swooping in between the branches of the
canopy snatching its prey from above and
below the harpy eagle is a terrifyingly
agile predator
it hunts by sight and hearing carefully
scanning the canopy for prey which it
can spot from huge distances
it has a grip strong enough to crush its
prey's bones in an instant and can lift
prey that weighs as much as its own body
weight
among the largest of the eagles a harpy
eagle's wingspan can reach to up to over
two meters
wings perfectly suited to maneuvering in
the dense forest vegetation
they can weigh up to 10 kilograms or
over 20 pounds yet can still fly at
speeds up to 80 kilometers per hour
packing a huge punch on impact for their
unfortunate victims
in one incident a harpy eagle even
nearly knocked a bbc cameraman
unconscious and could have killed him if
it weren't for the man's stab proof
kevlar vest
these eagles are arguably the most
powerful of all of the raptors
being a sloth or a monkey in harpy eagle
territory would be an unfortunate fate
but it's not just raw power that makes
the harpy eagle one of the deadliest
predators of the rainforest these eagles
are also incredibly intelligent
so intelligent that their smarts rival
that of their primate prey
the relationship between the eagles and
the monkeys that they hunt has evolved
into an extraordinary arms race of
cleverness
each pushing the other to adapt new
communication defenses and attack
strategies over time
with legendary strength and fearsome
hunting abilities the harpy eagle is a
force unmatched in the sky
how has nature crafted the harpy eagle
to be such a monstrous predator what is
it that makes the harpy eagle the
scariest killer of the sky
the first written record of the harpy
eagle is in carl linnaeus's 1758 systema
nature
he describes the bird as the vulture
harpia named after the greek
mythological spirit the harpy that had
the body of an eagle and the face of a
human
this comparison is fitting largely due
to the harpy eagle's facial disc
the facial disc is composed of feathers
that form a circle around the bird's
face which they can lift or lower as
they please when the feathers of the
facial disc are raised they help direct
sounds to the bird's ears which are
located on the sides of its head
it's a lot like when you cup your hands
behind your ears to hear something
better
this allows the eagles to pinpoint prey
in the dark dense forest where it hunts
harpies will often perch completely
still and completely silently as it
waits for prey to wander near them and
to help in spotting their prey harpy
eagles have some of the best eyesight of
any animal in the world
they can spot an item as small as 3
centimeters from 200 meters away
this level of acuity the ability to
resolve fine detail in their eyes far
exceeds our own
to test just how well eagles can see
researchers set up a clever experiment
they trained eagles to fly down a long
tunnel towards two tv screens one tv
would display a striped pattern and when
the birds land on it they get rewarded
with food the other tv displays a solid
gray color
the tvs were then separated so the eagle
had to make a choice at the start of the
trial and stick to it over the course of
the trials researchers would determine
from what distance the eagles can
discern the stripes and choose the
correct tb the eagles were found to be
able to discriminate detail that is four
times as fine as the finest detail that
we can see
a few features of an eagle's eyes make
them so sharp
for one thing eagles have large eyes for
their size 1.4 times greater than the
average for other birds of the same
weight and the eye is tube shaped
the tube shape produces a larger retinal
image and this retinal image is
transformed into a neural response by
the light sensitive elements of the eye
the photoreceptors
the more photoreceptors there are and
the less space between them the better
the visual acuity as the spacing between
photoreceptors decreases so does the
minimum size of the detail that can be
discriminated by an eye
however simply having more
photoreceptors spread all over the
retina would be energetically costly
because of this animal eyes have a
special central region with extremely
numerous and tightly packed
photoreceptors
this is called the fovea and it provides
the brain with the clearest vision of
any part of the eye
eagles have a much deeper fovea than
most animals giving them especially high
acuity vision for harpy eagles the
highest acuity occurs in their
peripheral vision at around 45 degrees
to the right and left of their head axis
and it's usually used for detecting prey
from a large distance
but pursuit raptors like the harpy eagle
have something else almost no other
animal has
a second shallower fovea that allows for
sharp vision in the frontal field of
view at 15 degrees to the right or left
of the head axis
these two fovea allow the eagles to see
two sharp images in their vision
simultaneously
this is why you can often see raptors
like this turning their head repeatedly
while looking at an object
they can't rotate their eyes and their
sockets so these movements are helping
to focus the object back and forth
between the deep and shallow fovea
having both regions of acute vision is
of course a huge benefit to these
predatory birds but having their most
acute vision in the side of their vision
causes a conflict for many raptors
especially ones that dive at prey at
high speeds
when going fast turning the head
sideways to view the prey that's in
front of them would cause a ton of
aerodynamic drag and slow the bird down
so to solve this raptors don't
necessarily follow a straight path to
their prey instead they dive along a
logarithmic spiral path with their heads
straight and one eye looking sideways at
the prey this is especially true for
birds like the diving peregrine falcons
harpy eagles don't fly or dive nearly as
fast but at 80 kilometers per hour they
still very much need to keep
aerodynamics in mind as they hunt
from wingtip to wingtip harpy eagles are
longer than many full-grown humans are
tall
with a wingspan of about two meters
across
with female harpies being almost twice
the size as males these wings are
immense but for the size of the rest of
their body and compared to other large
flying birds their wings are relatively
short
andean condors for example weigh about
the same as harpy eagles but have a
wingspan of over 3 meters across
this is because harpy eagles aren't
built for soaring
instead they're built to move more
nimbly from tree to tree through the
dense forest
their short broad wings help them be
highly agile and even give them the
ability to fly almost straight up so
they can attack prey from below as well
as above
like with all flying birds harpy eagles
are able to fly due to the structure of
their flight feathers or remages
unlike other feathers remages are
anchored to the bone and their primary
function is to aid in the generation of
both thrust and lift removages are
divided into primary and secondary
feathers based on their position along
the wing the primaries are the longest
of the flight feathers these feathers
are asymmetric with a shorter less
flexible leading edge that prevents
mid-air twisting
they occupy the outer half of the wing
and can be controlled and rotated
individually much like our own fingers
this rotation of the feathers controls
flight directions and adjusts lift and
air resistance as needed
for example if the primary feathers are
lifted and splayed the bird's flight
will slow and the altitude will drop if
the primary feathers are held tightly
together the bird's flight will be
faster and more precise and is often
done when chasing prey
this ability to morph the wing in
different flying situations gives flying
birds a maneuverability that aircraft
engineers could only dream of
secondary flight feathers cannot be
controlled as extensively but they
provide most of the lift by overlapping
to form an efficient airfoil tail
feathers or retraces are also essential
for flight they are needed for steering
and only the two most central feathers
attach to the bone
where the harpy eagle lacks length and
wingspan it makes up for in its long
tail which it uses like a rudder on a
boat to steer through dense vegetation
tail feathers are more symmetrical than
flight feathers but have increasing
levels of asymmetry towards the outer
pairs
and controlling most of this acrobatic
flight are the chest muscles which
attach to the sternum
the chest muscles and sternum are highly
developed in birds much more so than in
other vertebrates like mammals
but for the harpy eagle it's even more
extreme
soaring birds like the andean condor
have a comparatively small sternum and
less developed chest muscles once birds
like them are airborne they hardly need
to flap but harpy eagles with their
short wings and heavy weight and agile
lifestyle have a huge need for some of
the strongest flight muscles of any bird
and on top of this strength the harpy
eagle's legs can be as thick as a human
wrist
and its curved black talons are larger
than a grizzly bear's claws at 13
centimeters long these are the largest
talents of any bird of prey and can
exert over 50 kilograms of pressure
these claws are known to break bones in
an instant or snatch prey from trees
with a force stronger than a large dog's
jaws
this fierce hunting ability alone would
be enough to strike terror in the hearts
of the primates and sloths of south
america
but on top of this harpy eagles are
clever
so clever that they don't merely ambush
their prey but outsmart them in one of
the most interesting predator-prey
communication arms races ever observed
in the battle of survival in the animal
kingdom predators need to capture prey
and prey needs to avoid being captured
these simple truths have led to a
spectacular phenomenon predators and
prey throughout the world are locked in
all sorts of evolutionary arms races
one famous example of this is the arms
race between bats and moths
this arms race began when bats evolved
the ability to echolocate in order to
detect their moth prey in complete
darkness
in response moths evolved ears that
allow them to hear the echolocation and
evade capture
some bats then improved their attack
strategy by evolving stealthier
echolocation that is echolocation at
frequencies that can't be heard by moths
some moths in turn then evolved
ultrasonic clicks of their own that they
can use defensively during an attack and
so it goes on and on
these types of dynamics can be seen
throughout the animal kingdom but for a
long time relatively little was known
about how predators hunt primates in
particular and how primates might
acquire adaptive responses to counteract
such predation
so researchers began a somewhat brutal
observational experiment
boro colorado island is a biological
reserve island in the middle of the
panama canal
it's home to many species of primate
including marmosets spider monkeys and
most importantly to this study howler
monkeys
these howler monkeys lived in
approximately 65 troops each with an
average of 19 members
often primates develop predator-specific
calls specific calls that discriminate
between big cats snakes and eagles to
warn their fellow monkeys of the
specific type of danger that is near and
coordinate a defensive response but for
the last 100 years
the howler monkeys on borrow colorado
island have faced no major predators
no jaguars few snakes and most
importantly no eagles that is until 1999
when two radio-collared harpy eagles
were introduced
researchers wanted to know would the
borrow colorado monkeys have an
organized reaction to the
never-before-seen predators
and if they didn't how long would it
take for such a response to develop
as expected once the eagles were set
loose they wreaked havoc on the monkeys
both eagles were picking a howler monkey
off every three to four days
and at first the monkeys had one of two
responses to a harpy eagle attack
either they would act in a random
panicked and agitated manner with no
coordination between the monkeys or they
would remain totally calm completely
unaware of the danger before them
the howler monkeys had indeed lost their
ability to recognize the danger from the
harpy eagle thus becoming extremely
vulnerable to predation upon their
re-introduction this is not altogether
that surprising the surprising finding
however was the strategy the eagles used
to hunt their primate prey
instead of rapid stealth attacks like
you might expect the eagles would perch
in a tree nearby in plain view of the
monkey troop and observe the animals
then as if to make their presence known
they would utter a series of calls
literally the opposite of stealth
these calls always had the same acoustic
structure were only ever used before
prey pursuit and only when hunting for
primate prey
why would a predator let its prey know
that it's about to attack them
what happened after the harpy's call
gave researchers a hint if after the
harpy made its presence known with its
call and the howler monkey's response
was either minimal or chaotic the eagles
would attack
if instead the monkeys displayed a
coordinated defense response the harpies
would leave
and either find different monkeys to
prey upon or come back later and attack
using stealth
the harpy eagles call was being used to
gain critical information about its prey
by observing what happens after the call
the eagles are learning about the level
of prey alertness their escape ability
and their defense mechanisms
by probing the potential defense
strategies before initiating an attack
the eagle can assess the risk of the
confrontation and make a snap decision
whether or not it's a good use of their
time and energy
over time more and more of the monkey
troops established coordinated defenses
such as picking up the young and moving
them closer to the trunk of the tree
moving to more dense areas of the canopy
organizing themselves to literally mob
the eagle if it came too close or
producing an eagle-specific alarm call
after just a year nearly all of the
monkeys on the island had regained such
defense mechanisms
making hunting for the harpies more
difficult
researchers got to observe this predator
prey arms race play out in real time
a unique and valuable opportunity
but unfortunately for our curiosity the
experiment ended before the eagles could
adapt once more to the monkey's new
defense strategies
the harpies were removed from the island
after just one year but after they were
gone the howler monkeys maintained their
defense responses to recordings of the
harpy eagle calls for at least seven
months
which is how long they were observed for
no one knows for sure how long this
defense response will last in the howler
monkey population there
field biology of this sort unfortunately
can rarely continue on forever
but luckily an incredible new insight
into harpy eagle behavior was uncovered
proving in one more way that harpy
eagles are an incredible predator if
hunting primates in the rainforest isn't
your thing but neither is meal planning
and going to the grocery store life can
get hungry a popular reddit post the
other day mentioned this exact quandary
figuring out what you're going to have
for dinner every day for the rest of
your life is overwhelming
some comments in this thread suggested
simply just not eating others wished for
an iv drip of nutrients others suggested
eating the same exact thing every day
others suggested egg
the problem is i like food i like food a
lot i even like cooking food i don't
want to eat just egg i just don't have
time to go to the grocery store every
day and decide what to eat every day
i've often dreamed of having a
stay-at-home robot who can meal plan and
grocery shop for me every week until i
realized hellofresh can be that
hypothetical robot last year i signed up
for the three meal per week option and
it's been a godsend hellofresh offers a
wide variety of quick and easy recipes
that save me so much time their
step-by-step recipes are super easy to
follow and
ingredients helped me cut out prep time
so it's perfect for weeknight meals
there are 50 weekly options which are
very fun to browse and you can opt for
veggie pescetarian and fit and wholesome
meals to stick to your health and diet
goals
the meals are always changing and always
delicious with meals like bulgogi lime
pork tenderloin mushroom tortilla melts
or garlic butter shrimp scampi that's
your sneak peek into what i'm eating
next week
so if you think this sounds good but
aren't quite certain about it you've
come to the right place
if you go to hellofresh.com and use code
realscience16 you'll get 16 free meals
and 3 surprise gifts i genuinely can't
recommend trying it enough
so to free up your time and eat more
delicious meals go to hellofresh.com and
use code realscience16
for up to 16 free meals and 3 surprise
gifts as always thanks for watching and
if you'd like to watch something else
right now you can watch our last video
about the effects of long-term space
flight on the human body or watch real
engineering's latest video about the
imminent death of the international
space station